20 عاما لم تكفي افغانستان لتتنفس بها
السعداء حتى جثمت عليها حكومه طالبان
مجددا قبل نحو عامين ومع عودتها ارجعت
معها تاريخا في احتجاز الغربيين كرهائن
مقابل مبادلتهم بخدمه سياسيه تقول صحيفه
ان الطالبان تلجا الاعتقالات ممنهجه
لرعايه امريكيين من اجل تامين النفوذ
السياسي ضد الولايات المتحده وفي هذا
السياق طرحت الصحيفه اربع نظريات اولا
تهدف طالبان الى تخليص افغانستان من اي
وجود غربي لتستطيع احكام السيطره على
قيمها كمنع الفتيات من التعليم اما ثانيا
رجحت المصادر الامنيه ان تخطط طالبان
لاستخدام الرهائن كورقه سياسيه تضمن بها
مبادله الاسرى
وربما تعتبرها خطوه للضغط على اداره
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن للافراج عن
مليارات الدولارات من الاحتياطيه الاجنبيه
المجمده بسبب العقوبات الماليه الاميركيه
وانتهاء من نظريه الاخيره تسعى طالبان من
خلال السجناء السياسيين الى المحاوله
بالاعتراف بحكومتها في كل المحافل الدوليه
التي ما تزال تعتبر في نظر امريكا والغرب
خريجه عن القانون وغير مرغوب فيها
وقدرا مصادر الصحيفه الامريكيه ان
المعتقلين الغربيين اكثر من عشره وسط
زياده مقلقه في دبلوماسيه الرهائن
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات